the first guy though that we need to
talk about is one of the big names on
the market we've kept our eye on the
possibility that receiver juju smith
shuster steelers mvp 2018 a bit of news
that
really brought about the end of antonio
brown's time in pittsburgh we thought
smith shuster would move on but when the
big money didn't flow in his direction
staying in pittsburgh became an option
one year eight million dollar deal they
used votable years to drive down the cap
charge because they don't have the cap
space the ravens were the other team
that was a finalist for juju that would
have been something if he'd gone to
baltimore i'm told that baltimore
offered more on the base
amount of nine million for one year not
eight million plus incentives
up to another three and a half million
more shireen but juju decides to
continue his career in pittsburgh for a
year and then maybe next year he's in a
position to make more on the open market
and mike they just now announced this
deal and announced the avoidable years
on the back end so it is official now
and we said yesterday this was probably
the best move for him if he wasn't going
to get the big money that he thought it
was going to get and obviously he didn't
get that big money that multi-year deal
that the best move on a one-year deal
was to go back to pittsburgh a place
you're familiar with a place where ben
roethlisberger knows you very well a
place where you can go prove yourself
perhaps this year and get a bigger deal
next year when there's going to be more
money on the market so i think this was
a good move for for juju
smith schuster to return to pittsburgh
yes he turned down bigger uh deals
elsewhere kansas city and the eagles
also reportedly were in on him eagles
weren't awful
as much deals
ravens for sure so
he had options to go elsewhere for more
money but it wasn't enough mike to
entice him to leave pittsburgh so he
gets a chance to go back and get a
bigger deal next year on the open market
chiefs got involved too late to get his
attention and the number wasn't enough
to get his attention he was locked into
the steelers or the ravens and look if
he'd gone to the ravens the risk he's
taking is he's rarely going to see the
football in pittsburgh i don't know how
he fits into that depth chart now
shereen because they've got some good
young receivers there and i'm surprised
they felt compelled to bring him back
one more year with ben roethlisberger
could help next year though
when the steelers presumably step into
their post-been existence
that's when it's going to make sense for
juju to move on because when free agency
begins unless the steelers pull off a
trade that we're going to know about
before free agency begins
juju would be taking a job to stay in
pittsburgh without knowing what
certainly who the steelers quarterback
would be in 2022
which would make it harder for him
depending upon who the quarterback is to
have the kind of year that he would want
in 2022 to cash in in 23 so i think the
plan is
have a big year
see what's out there next year
and then next year maybe it's baltimore
or kansas city or the jets or somewhere
else for juju smith shuster but an upset
for him to stay in pittsburgh a good
outcome for the steelers and as you said
the deal is now official the deal has
announced juju is sticking around for
year number five far less than what the
franchise tag would have been some
people were surprised he didn't
franchise tag him well he's not a number
one receiver and that's something that
one executive told me today one of the
reasons why
the free agency money isn't there for
the receivers this year apart from the
fact that there are plenty of good young
receivers coming into the league every
year now
there's no clear number one out there
there's no guy that you're gonna game
plan against kenny galladay if he's
healthy maybe chris godwin's not a
number one guy i'm still surprised the
buccaneers franchise tagged him alan
robinson as of yesterday i'm not signing
my franchise tag then the bears flirt
with kenny galladay and what happens
alan robinson
beats a path to the
franchise tender and signs the thing
because the bears may have
realized why are we paying this guy 17.9
million dollars when the market just
isn't there so smart move by juju to get
what he can and to focus shireen on next
year and some of these other guys like
gallaudet got to be wondering
what what's what's really going to be
out there
once we get into the second week of free
agency
no question mike it's been a
weird year for these receivers and
something we sort of expected going into
free agency two interesting things about
juju's contract a he is the the third
receiver to sign a second contract with
the steelers in the modern era the other
two of course are heinz ward and a b got
those second contracts even if it isn't
the multi-year deal he wanted he will
stay on a second contract for for one
year and the other thing you look at
with the steelers mike is how much
they've sacrificed on defense and
they're they're up against the cap as we
said we know that squeezed but they've
lost four defensive guys who were key to
that defense last year bud dupree mike
hilton vince williams and tyson olualu
they played 2100 snaps among them last
year that's an awful lot of snaps for a
really good defense so juju going back
to this team to me puts a lot on the
offense to get this done because the
defense may not be quite as good as what
it has been last year in previous years
because we know that defense has carried
the steelers so a lot to me is riding on
big ben
finding a rejuvenation for one more year
and trying to get over the hump and now
he's got his receiver back to be able to
try to do that
at age 39 and just two years removed
from his elbow going in week two so
i i still believe that by the time we
get to november or december both sides
are gonna say why did we do this as it
relates to ben and the steelers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports